der brh exit jetzt ist er da fast vier
jahre nach dem referendum und drei
premierminister später verlassen 66,2
millionen britinnen und treten die
europäische union
damit rutscht die eu insgesamt unter die
halbe milliarde einwohner
auch die 73 britischen abgeordneten im
eu parlament sagte diese woche bei jeder
zehnte eu-abgeordnete durch den dreck
cit verliert europa zudem seine
zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft 2,4
billionen euro hatte zuletzt das
bruttoinlandsprodukt betragen
der ist united kingdom hatte so einen
anteil von etwa 15 prozent am
bruttoinlandsprodukt der eu
zugleich war das vereinigte königreich
der zweitgrößte nettozahler der eu knapp
sieben milliarden zahlten sie zuletzt
mehr ein als sie herausbekommen nur wir
deutschen brachten unter dem strich noch
mehr ein
nicht nur die insel auf der anderen
seite des ärmelkanals rückt von uns ab
auch wichtige seegebiete drum herum
gehören dann nicht mehr zur eu nahezu
100% des nordsee herings den wir essen
wurden bisher vor der britischen küste
gefangen auch von deutschen fischer doch
es bleibt noch zeit bis die praxistür
tatsächlich zu fällt bis zum 31 12 2020
wird das vereinigte königreich
wirtschaftlich noch wie ein eu land
behandelt
solange können also noch alle ohne
schranken hierunter arbeiten und wohnen
erst danach sollen die neuen regelungen
rund um den break it beschlossen sein
und in kraft treten der praxis lässt
sich auch jetzt noch zeit